oh goes locos before your lame movie
what are these tally marks keeping track
up obviously aren't days mind if he's
keeping track of something wouldn't you
at least add up the tallies for each
month this kid dies a rock to his ankles
so that he'll be sunk into the sea land
on the Flying Dutchman and cause the
ship to float to the surface
how tha does he know this will work also
I know we're supposed to remember all
the stuff at the end of Pirates of the
Caribbean the curse of the dead
strangers chests at World's End but are
you telling me that if one visit will
was able to tell Henry all about the
Dutchman's whereabouts and how to get it
to the surface
we'll be severely overestimates my
desire to keep track of which ship is
which after four movies they know your
hair the real question is why aren't
they already on deck ship made a pretty
dramatic rise to the surface also either
captain of this ship now why does it
matter if they know he's here I thought
you took over after the third movie I
want you to come home and this kid
really feels a lot of love for a guy
he's seen one time in his life also why
did he come here and risk his life just
to tell his dad he knows something that
can break his curse without getting that
thing first so about those guys you were
worried about a minute ago did they get
lost on the way to do whatever you were
worried about them doing so despite it
not having any kind of anchor and being
pushed aside by the week of the flying
Dutchman's ascent this tiny boat is
still just hanging out waiting for a
little Henry back in the day human
hearing was so good they could detect
someone yelling overall the cannon fire
and hundreds of men shouting and I sold
them all the Disney's so they could make
more god-awful sequels in this franchise
for at least the next 50 years
this one is clearly disturbed why
haven't you tackled him yet why has he
been allowed to speak this long IRA to
the Caribbean at World War Z Zend of all
the jail joints and all the ships in all
the seas he walks into mine for too many
years the Dragon Boat classic curse
that's the key to our escape he's
bottled us which people it's Jesus
Christ the setup for this movie is no
different than the first one and really
how many of these movies are gonna have
some cursed ship with a bunch of dead
semi dead and undead dudes on it
[Music]
because in this very movie he'll give
away his compass which will somehow
bring me daylight and do nothing else in
particular right
honestly Henry could simply not tell
Jack about Salazar at all and he'd be
totally okay there's absolutely no deal
struck here no danger so why did he ever
need to tell Jack about this encounter
then then tell no tales roll frigates
movie reminds you of which movie this is
13 minutes in but I'll forget five
minutes later anyway accused of
practicing witchcraft before you die do
you have anything to confess I confess
that I'm not a witch that I have a woman
of science this is either the late 1700s
or the early 2020s
I can't figure out which he might
confess that while we've been talking I
pitched this look and there's absolutely
no guards will stop me after I escape
myself drunk bimbo ex machina also what
a crazy scenario where this movies come
up with Jack apparently had no trouble
getting into this safe managed to take a
sex partner into the safe with him and
they apparently drank and on the money
all while this crew waited until the
bank unveiled the safe the next morning
to try and steal it
do I have that right also safe sex no
there wasn't even if she somehow buried
beneath that gold she certainly would
have been awakened by him landing
directly on top of her as he rolled out
she appeared out of thin air maybe she's
the witch they're looking for they also
am I the only one who's rooting for the
British to kill Jack once and for all it
takes a lot to make this American root
for 18th century British people but five
movies like this will do it know also
because nobody likes money everyone
stands here and watches the bank
literally drift away while also not
killing an even easier to kill Jack
Sparrow is there rope just lying here on
the floor was being used for the heist
it seems only to be here to give Jack
yet another cheap escape from an
unescapable situation this would never
be the first thing he says to her or the
way he says it ever forced double
entendres are the weakest double
entendres also what if you looking for
through a telescope in the middle of the
day what if it was pointed to the Sun
careful play with your Herschel too much
you might go blind there's no way this
Bank makes this turn unless it's on a
track for pete's sake Fast Five was less
ridiculous and when you're taking physic
lessons from The Fast franchise is it
maybe time to call it a day
you see my mind didn't the bank just
come through here
it left Jeff behind a minute ago so why
would it be coming anywhere near him
normally this type of thing would break
this encounter but it seemed worse this
thing's been through five transformers
17 fast and furious is four and a
quarter of these movies and travel
through time so this ain't no thing
black pill is never left me son honestly
I don't know which is more ridiculous
but the movie thinks I remember why this
ship is in his pocket or that it thinks
I even care
the pirate barbers old these seas now I
sure I'm glad you clarified that it's
the pirate Barbosa because I would have
thought you met Fred Barbosa the tuna
King facing Jack bad-luck dogs you day
and night
Gibbs clearly hasn't seen the other four
movies or at least the last ten minutes
of this one
watch it seagull that's our job my
father is trapped by such a curse your
weather causes I'm not supported by
science neither ghosts so you have gone
mad but you came here to talk to this
guy about the Trident but you do believe
in but you don't believe in ghosts or
curses
so Poseidon possible curses not got it
but this meth has never been seen nor it
by any man okay oh so the map is
cock-blocked then make sense is the
diary of Galileo Galilei he spent his
life searching for the Trident Galileo
was a pretty smart dude and we find out
later that basically we just have to
follow some stars to find it
you mean with all the information he had
he couldn't do that give me the bottle
shouldn't the bartender have to accept
this trade before any of this reverse
the curse nonsense actually starts to
happen for some reason Sauron dies again
in this movie also if my memory serves
it's not like this is the first time
jack has given this thing to someone
else why didn't that set things in
motion why is this bartender so eager to
grab the compass does he know what it is
is it an earthquake coz if I think
something you're trying to give me is
causing an earthquake I'm sending you
the hell away from my bar has given away
the compass Oh what they're free from is
anyone's guess I suppose it could mean
constant darkness but everyone on this
boat is still cursed and dead looking
and can't touch land so are they free
from luckily for the plot of this movie
Kareena was put into a Cell complete
with the moon roof so that she could
read the map that you can only read
under a Blood Moon can we talk about how
sparrow set this up later we see he used
some sort of hay to create the shape but
but that he bind it with stand it up
with how does it balance impossible
scare Sparrow is impossible gross
you do still want us to kind of actually
like Jack Sparrow right moving oh and
you could be the one who holds the scene
would it become all that you once were
great I believe this is exactly how
Johnny Depp approaches this character
now he calls it method sleeping the
child can never be found funny after
four movies Barbosa still think stuff
like finding the Trident is impossible
but all the other mind-blowing bullshit
in these movies well as possible the
data containing the cer able to step on
dry
but why they told us Davy Jones could
only step on dry land every ten years
and that was a rule specific to the
Flying Dutchman but apparently no dead
men at sea could touch dry land
arbitrary curse rules continue to be
arbitrary my ways that screenwriter
speak for we have no clue we'd also if
this woman is an honest-to-god witch why
isn't she dead they were ready to kill
not a witch Karina almost immediately
time to make a deal with the dead this
witch told him that the cost of entering
this room would be blood but she just
gives the compass to him without any
payment because something something in
the past Jackie boy I can't believe they
got Pete best to play jacks uncle why
are these guards even allowing this we
strip away all human rights and decency
here but hey if you need to have a
conversation with another inmate while
we are dragging you somewhere by all
means go ahead the biggest proof that
she may actually be a witch is that this
works most of you have the mind of a guy
I hate to bring up stuff like this in a
movie filled with pirates which is
zombies curses and trident but what this
town square really have dual executions
going on with one hanging and another a
beheading is this if you could just be
patient Oh
this goes on for some time and none of
the kill happy Brits decides to kill
someone and end this stupid scene and
movie
I guess Henry knew there would be some
sort of delay in killing Karina and Jack
girls this rescue attempt would have
been super late this random spectator
would be amazing at cinemasins no son
I'm just a diversion divergent avulsion
kill Oh tease you have a sword she's
being hung with a rope swords can cut
ropes jeez do I really have to spell
this out for you also pretty sure that
rope is long enough that Little Miss
can't be wrong could just step off that
trapdoor you know if she was really
worried about dying and stuff she can be
caught here with that much slack still
in the rope this hanging was never going
to work unless the goal was simply to
break her ankles when she hit the ground
save your neck then we know who Jack's
crew was or did he just stumble upon
some people who would do this job and it
just happened to be Jack's old crew
sitting where your left hand is I said
well not if you're holding everything
but my West how exactly did he catch her
if his hand is inappropriately placed
did he go to the Weinstein school of
catching things then I bestow upon you
the owner citing name for a small
donation you expect us to be
apparently yes that's what the movie is
saying and there is no explanation for
why this works how much of this idiot
are we supposed to put up with did
someone take a poll yeah look at this if
I kill the coward the witch hags
then do it already you really think we
can find the Trident seriously these
people came back to work for Jack
because of some mythical Trident why are
they tying these people up because by
God if you tell me that it's a fifty
Shades sequel called fifty shades of
gray beard ma Corina expects a bunch of
don't assholes and know what she means
by pointing to the sky okay sure they
didn't throw him in the seat but surely
if he landed like that he's at least got
a concussion and might be on his way to
bleeding out also pretty sure a
full-sized human being landing from
fifteen feet into a wooden boat would
make enough noise to give away the ruse
I went - no way that pirate is going
with that witch Jesus
Kareena wrote all the directions on her
prison wall that's amazing so we've both
spent our lives searching for our
fathers well know we've seen your dad
and you know where he is you even
stupidly nearly drowned yourself to see
him but I kind of admire that you're
looking for any reason to find something
in common with this woman just because
you can't see something doesn't mean
it's not bad skip the son do something
I'm so uptight
we've seen Salazar's undead army
immediately kill people when he taps his
sword but this guy decides now I'll just
put my sword to his throat maybe he'll
talk his way out of it there's no
emergency there's no mercy the Creed of
Apple eating assholes everywhere this
type of bullet physics was disproven by
Mythbusters but I guess since
Mythbusters didn't exist back then those
bullets didn't get the message
scrawny debt also young Johnny Depp CGI
mixed with another actor basically looks
like what happens if he told the
computer what the young version would
look like but young Johnny Depp doesn't
look like this really take a look at a
picture from Nightmare on Elm Street or
21 Jump Street or even Sweeney Todd the
Demon Barber of Fleet Street well maybe
not that last one one ship was trying to
escape through this boat one that
despite the clear and decisive victory
by Salazar still had a full crew and
sustained no damage the magic of movies
you see Salazar is actually a good guy
in this story even though he didn't want
to show mercy to some filthy pirates
after the battle was over jack is
definitely the bad guy here but because
we supposedly love Jack the story's
flipped on its head so now that we have
this convenient backstory for Salazar
and young Jack how exactly did Salazar
know it was the compass that cursed him
again and furthermore how did the
compass cursor
dad Barbosa was saved at the last minute
by a Jack Sparrow organ story I hope I
was this stupid well actually the first
movie was pretty clever oh you mean the
people carry on them say you know we'll
be cool half dead skeleton sharks
chasing their heroes to shore but why
would Salazar even have sharks didn't
you hear me skeleton sharks what's good
even care
cinemasins cares motherfuckers
cinemasins cares also right to say it
the sharks from Finding Nemo look more
realistic than these do ya distract them
they magically home get on Jack Sparrow
why would clothes distract them and why
haven't they smashed his boat into
smithereens yet if they could do that
then why didn't they do it from the very
beginning I send zombie sharks
well unless they're also standing on
some sort of moisture then they're
totally okay the spirit world must have
a terrible time figuring out how much is
enough water and he can't stand on the
land scenario pool traps bro so how did
you set that one up on a three second
delay if you never escape that Islands
our waste time killing all the barbosa's
underlings and not Barbosa himself
they'd be so mad about Jack being on
land
wake up Spyro it's time to pay your debt
of course they crashed on an unknown
uncharted unreachable island and there
are pirates there who know Jack and have
a beef with it congratulations
it's your wedding day god damn it this
movie wants to be 90 minutes but like
the gluttony victim in seven someone
kept feeding it until it burst
II like seafood I'm surprised there
wasn't a real-life mutiny on this set
when the actors and crew were told we
need to spend an entire week filming
Jack Sparrow's fake wedding even if it
was just a day or a few hours it was too
much this brings up another question why
can Salazar step on a boat that just
happens to be on water and still be
considered on water if he's stepping on
wood
why didn't you get a couple glass boxes
filled them with seawater and use them
as shoes we had something sharp few were
the Farrelly Brothers gross toenail
scene we all know this fucking toenail
should be able to break them out of the
cell but man are we not entertained also
they'll break out of the cell and
quietly steal a rowboat from this
British ship without a pink soul knowing
about it
these bumbling pirates are quite amazing
off screen where did you get that
you see I know this book oh come on no
you don't you remember a book phew also
this is his daughter isn't it me yes we
get it she's his daughter
one more convenient confusing and
convoluted story point to try and
obscure that this plot is actually
thinner than a skeleton pirate shadow
sounds artist Ines to destroy the
British ship but my thought he hated
pirates not other people who hate
pirates why not take on the Black Pearl
in tandem I'm just gonna sin this but no
Jack probably can jump on all these wet
cannons in the rain and not slip once
why would I ever question that of course
the ship is cursed and can do crazy
things why is this glorified hood
ornament just now taking part in this
battle so why didn't Salazar just turn
his ship in a pirate pac-man like he's
done so many times to so many other
ships in this movie he clearly doesn't
care what kills Jack as long as he dies
so why go through all this trouble after
seeing Jack escaped so many situations
he finally gets rammed by a cannon with
the weight of an entire ship thrusting
it and he survives Congrats you found
the secret island but how exactly did
you survive sound was our ship for the
last 10 minutes this crew has killed
everything with ease and impunity and
actually cut that British ship in half
with a single bite what is taking them
so long to finish off this weak band of
mortals
the islands sure you need to get off the
ship can't spare a half second to spear
Sparrow through the heart before you go
please
guess the magical MacGuffin awaits it
better have a 42 printed on it somewhere
because that thing is apparently the
answer to life the expanded universe and
everything so the Ruby she's using here
was on Galileo's diary but where did
Galileo get it
decidin was the one who made the map
that no man can read so that means he
would have broken off this piece of Ruby
himself and then what he gave to
somebody he chucked it into the sea and
somehow someone found that Ruby and
thought to himself who knows Ruby I bet
it's the key to finding Poseidon's
trident I will dedicate my life to it
besides island is addictive people who
figured out his stupid map once you
possess the Leaving there's no coming
back you will be dropped in his body
forever wait so they can go on land if
they possess someone setting aside that
it's yet another new rule that we are
just now hearing about how do they even
know these rules does every curse come
with a handbook welcome be your curse
here are a few things you need to know
before you get started what is it this
year with movies where the protagonist
go through all this to find an artifact
only to have to go through more after
they've done all the hard stuff this and
transform is found at the same movie
basically
what does the Trident even do so he was
able to unpossessed Henry's body which
we were told was impossible without the
Trident but his skin condition hadn't
cleared up one bit so in its current
state it can take care of one curse but
not others Salazar's fingertips this
still doesn't kill jack what did she
just do there it looked like she was
reaching into the water but why did she
give the oncoming curse pirates I
haven't said no was she busting their
barnacles does anybody understand
anything about what's going on here this
movie isn't even trying to keep it a
secret that it's one big flushing toilet
and every curse is held inside what how
do you make that leap of logic the idea
that this trident could break curses was
one thing but that it stores curses the
Trident an incredible artefact of power
wielded by a sea God cannot penetrate
the defenses of Galileo's diary divide
I've never seen such nonsense get
figured out this quickly also now that
they're going to break the trident to
break the curse how do curses get broken
from here on out or curse is eliminated
forever so the water is now an issue for
you but the half a head thing that's
still cool why is the water returning so
slowly is there some sort of gradual
gravity field release why wouldn't it
just release immediately this tattoo is
so ridiculous it might as well have said
for Kareena the daughter I gave away to
an orphanage and it would have been no
worse I mean this special map that no
man can read is tattooed on his body for
a lame parentage reveal why not just
have Maury Povich drop into the middle
of the sea and reveal it
how is Barbosa this far above them
didn't he knock them off the chain hope
he doesn't know how to gravity you will
right Oh totally just another one of
those find out you have a father in the
same moment he's sacrificing his life
for you days you what did you do that
for
just checking it's truly you know sort
of ghost run Henry as fast and as far
away from her as your sea legs will take
you run now after breaking the Trident
wheels curse was lifted and this movie
didn't even show it on screen a big
moment for a legacy character in fact
why isn't he already back on land the
curse was lifted in what you still had
to do more work let me tell you a tale a
tale of the greatest treasures and
learns in that that's its hello I just
watched it no you don't Elizabeth didn't
tag along with Henry to greet will
because she knew her surprise cameo
would delight the five people still left
in the theater
Jack Sparrow on deck seriously what's
changed he didn't get one red cent on
your Poseidon Adventure
you left Jack because of the lack of
money nothing's different
but yeah I'll he'll Jack Sparrow just in
case you forgot that you just watched a
fifth movie squeezed out of a 16 minute
amusement park ride post-credits it was
a dream but was it nonsense completely
undermines entire film by revealing that
claw handed tentacle face guy is still
somehow cursed and also not dead and
also who the hell even cares anymore
a major Luca Brasi sleeps with the
fishes hello James welcome do you like
the island my grandmother had an island
nothing to boast of you could walk
around it in an hour but still he was it
was a paradise for us I'm looking for a
buyer Jack Sparrow I need to speak with
you she was a fine ship
[Music]
my buddy hope you find your dad
that's no ship sir it's a Space Station
what I'm Batman I'd like to take his his
face which but you are just as one they
dressed me up like this